career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice one of my good friends dropped by
today with his brand new book pastor max
lecato yes the max lucado is sitting to
my right i've been blessed to become
friends with him many many years ago and
we've gotten to talk about uh his book
of the year because he writes one about
every 20 minutes and
so it's easy if you just go with
quantity and not quality
well i don't know with over 100 and what
30 million books sold now we'll go with
the quality aspect of that but uh max
has got another book out and everything
he writes i read he is an incredible
person an incredible friend incredible
man one of the top pastors in america
today you can check out his website at
maxlocato.com
and of course he pastors over in san
antonio
texas the new book is you were made for
this moment
courage for today and hope for tomorrow
almost like you wrote that during a
pandemic i did i did
in fact i was
going a different direction with a
different sermon series at our church
and then the pandemic exploded
and um
and it was my turn to preach at the
church and i i thought boy we've got to
do something on this whole theme of
global calamity and we had never studied
through the book of esther
the old testament book of esther and i
started reading through those nine
chapters and i thought that's that's
exactly what uh what we need for this
season of course when i wrote it dave i
i thought well the by the time i
finished the book the pandemic will be
over with that comment here we still
well it is and then it comes back and
then it is then it comes back but yeah
so
courage for today and hope for tomorrow
the story of esther is so
powerful
i made sure my daughters
when they were growing up really got
that story because a she was beautiful
and b
she was unbelievably
courageous uh put her life on the line
for others sure did and uh took a chance
walking into the king and so
how did you weave that into this idea of
dealing with worldwide pandemic comedy
yeah you you know the um as you remember
mordecai the uncle and esther his uh
niece uh were uh in exile they were
three generations removed we're fifth
century bc by the way for your listeners
and uh in the persia which our world
today has nothing to compare with
ancient persia
if 50 of the population twice the land
mass of the united states and uh the
king was xerxes uh he was more of a
drinker than a thinker he just kind of
did whatever he wanted to do misogynist
uh power hungry and then he had a
right-hand man named haman that always
rhymes with hangman which is appropriate
because he was a murderer turned exactly
and he wanted to kill all the jews and
so that's kind of the context and then
in his court was mordecai
uh a jew but that mordecai did not tell
people he was jewish and he had this
niece who became queen without telling
anybody she was jewish and so i know
that they are heroes but in the
beginning they were clandestine in their
faith but it was a crisis that forced
them to uh be forthcoming about their
faith esther
mordecai refused to bow before haman
esther put her uh life on the line by
appearing before king xerxes without any
invitation
and literally they saved the entire
jewish nation in a time of great crisis
yeah
and there's something about standing up
for the right thing
yeah that goes into this um
and yet
but the way they did it was not violent
the way they did it was
real strength uh wiersby says meekness
is not weakness it's power under control
that's it and um how do we right-size
our view of god to inspire us to live
that way yeah and i'm glad you mentioned
god because the book of esther's famous
for not mentioning god
you know it's it's one of the two books
in the bible where the name of god
doesn't appear uh but as john calvin
stated centuries ago his fingerprints
are on every paragraph i mean god's
sovereignty is woven uh throughout this
this entire story and i think the big
message of esther
is that we need to have a bigger view of
god
i mean a huge view of god if if if
you're a jew in fourth or fifth century
uh bc persia you feel like a mosquito in
comparison to the persian empire and
they're going to come down on you with
their heavy boots at any moment and then
just from a moment to the next god
rewrites and reroutes the story so maybe
there's a listener today who feels like
you're overwhelmed or
just just coming undone by everything
just believe in a big god and he's going
to help you trust him
max lucado is my guest this segment here
on the show the book is you were made
for this moment it is available tomorrow
in bookstores and you order it today
from online amazon or wherever else you
can of course get it very very quickly
since it starts tomorrow courage for
today and hope for tomorrow also they're
doing a live event tomorrow night you
can register for free at
faithgateway.com
slash moment and it'll be all about this
book it will tony dunchie's going to be
with us
tony evans and his entire family natalie
grant and my precious wife dealing as of
40 years last month all right yeah
that's a really good lineup yeah and i'm
surprised they let me on the program
well sometimes if we organize it we get
to do stuff with cool people that's
right
that's a couple of cool tonys right
there they're both great men all of
those folks are great that's that's
pretty incredible so again the book is
you were made for this moment courage
for today hope for tomorrow what's the
main
takeaway you hope people get from this
i hope people um
will consider the possibility that they
were made for this moment you know that
phrase comes from what mordecai said to
esther
you were made for a time such were made
for a time such as this and she says
okay i'll go i'll appear before the king
if i perish i perish i believe that
we are on the planet right now for this
purpose that god determined our
generation he determined our zip code he
determined our nation
and there is something in you there's
something in me there's something in
every person that god can use
to advance his cause and help his people
and so the real question is not
uh why me but the real question is god
how how can you use me and if we can
make that shift in our mindset and your
story is the perfect illustration of
this dave i know that you had tough days
early in your career when bankruptcy was
knocking on your door and then look how
you use that and god used that to bless
millions of people all over the planet
yours truly being one of them and so we
appreciate your money you're an example
of courage for all of us you're a good
man we appreciate you pastor max locato
this book is a must read you were made
for this moment
if you were wondering if you were
[Music]
we can both answer the question yes you
were
and when you read through this it'll
confirm it courage for today hope for
tomorrow pick it up anywhere great books
are sold pastor good to be with you my
friends thank you
thanks for hanging out
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones as we talk
about your life and your money it's a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five david is in dallas hi
david welcome to the ramsey show
hello dave this is dave from there i
want to congratulate you on everything
that's going on and max
definitely has some great introductions
to today's topics yeah yeah absolutely
i've been following i've been following
you with my family for well over 15
years and i can say your program works
well thank you sir because i facilitated
fpu numerous times
went through the entire process baby
step 7 edm
wow from there the biggest improvements
over here is that the life insurance
chapter is a very important item oh no
i'm having to exercise the life
insurance policy on my wife that passed
away last month oh no
i'm sorry david
what happened
uh it basically looks like it's covered
related oh no and how uh how long were
y'all married
22 years wow
i'm so sorry
how can we help today
uh from there i have two children an 18
year old and 16 year old and what i'm
trying to what i want your opinion on is
perhaps the best one of the structures
for doing the with the life insurance
payout
from there the two big things i'm
looking at is one version of it is all
of the money can come straight to me and
then from there i do come up with some
type of investment or you know real
estate of some sort
or there's another strategy that i'm
thinking about of disclaiming part of it
and letting it split to each of the kids
and
the question i have though is that is
that going to be is that going to mess
up my kids by having too much money too
early too young i think they're
responsible but i'm sure i'm concerned
about
messing up their relationships for their
potential mates and new spouses as they
entered into their new adult life yeah
how much life insurance is involved
about 250k okay
all right
and your net worth is a total of what
about 3.6 good for you well done
um i can tell you what i would do and
then i'll tell you why okay
uh i would take it as a lump sum to you
and make it part of your estate that you
leave to your kids
that does away with all your worries
of the other things and you can
distribute it to them as they have shown
themselves capable of carrying the
weight
of wealth
wealth is a blessing and a curse
it's a blessing and that you get to do a
lot of wonderful things with it it's a
curse in that is heavy because it
requires means you are responsible for
managing a lot of god's money
and god's stuff and god's assets and the
more stuff you own the more repairmen
you have to know
and so the good news is you get to do a
lot of wonderful things with generosity
when you're wealthy you get to feed
hungry kids you get to do wonderful
helpful things you get to do nice things
for your family and yourself
and it just gives you a more of a
stress-free
version of life that's why we call it
financial peace two words that don't go
together
like congress
congress intelligence i don't know is
that a thing but anyway uh oh fouchy
math that's one that doesn't go together
but um the uh
i'm looking for oxymorons here airline
service there's another one but um
okay but anyway yeah that's uh uh i just
put it into your name and that that way
you don't have any you don't have some
teenagers and you're worried about the
weight on them i want them to have just
the margin
the room to grieve without any extra
weight of anything right now the loss of
their mom what are you thinking john
david you said it was a month ago
yes
yeah
along with dave i
i really don't want people making those
type of decisions
for six months nine months and letting
the smoke clear on some of this and the
temptation is when you've lost
somebody's important and as
uh as a cornerstone to your existence as
your wife you clearly love her and she
was an integral part of your every
breath you took
it's it's natural to want to start
trying to control every variable in your
life including the money the this the
this to this and you start thinking five
years ten years down the road that's a
brain that in a heart and a spirit that
is just grasping for control
and i want you to park that money and
keep take like dave said taking a lump
sum and just spend the season grieving
the loss of your best friend of your
wife
and that's going to be relinquishing
some control getting around some buddies
that you care about and you love and
that will just sit with you and some of
these things that feel so pressing right
now tend to clear themselves up over six
months over a year
um and well if you ca and you've done so
well financially you don't you're not
having to go to work on monday to make
you know make the electric bill
and so i want you to spend a season
grieving and just like dave said hold up
hold on to that money right now and the
rest of that stuff will take care of
itself over the next few years an
interesting
technicality that adds to this
suggestion and makes it possible is
you can transfer any amount of your
estate
to anyone while you're live with no
estate taxes and no gift taxes under the
unified estate tax credit up to
the federal exemptions
now word is that president biden is
getting ready to lower the federal
exemption considerably but it's not
going to be down to 3.6 or 3.85
if we add 250 to it so if you move the
money into your name
uh later on you could move it to their
names under the unified estate tax
credit with no tax implications
whatsoever and so that gives you the
ability to delay this decision yeah to
not have to do it right now
and um
it's not i i wouldn't put it on my
teenagers
um
now uh but i would begin to talk to them
not this minute but
later in the year
about the money that you have and what
it's going to look like when they manage
it and you know if you're doing heroin
you're not going to be in the will
because i don't want to finance your
death
if you're misbehaving in other ways i
don't want to finance your misbehavior
that's not a blessing then that's when
wealth is a curse so
in order to
qualify to manage god's money our kids
have to be behaving god's ways
it's also a good moment i'm assuming
they followed the plan they've been
teaching it so i imagine he's got a
rhythm where him and his wife did a
budget every month and they talked about
short-term and long-term financial goals
this can be a masterful moment for his
kids legacy
for them to become a part of this
monthly budget you keep that same
meeting that you had with your wife
every month just invite them along and
say here's what bills look like here's
what this all looks like absolutely
carrie's in naples florida hi carrie
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave and dr john um i
wanted to call in and ask my husband and
i are 28 29 we're on baby steps uh four
and six
we are kind of at a crossroads we have
about 100 000 in the bank right now 30
of that's kind of earmarked for our
emergency fund so we've got 70 where
we're trying to figure out if we should
we started investing kind of late so
um i'm wondering if i should be dumping
like maybe 30 000
just into investments to catch up a
little bit on our investments because
you know the money's working harder for
sure what's your household
if you want to follow your plan you can
do that but you're not following our
plan right now
you're not on baby steps four and six
baby step four is 15 of your income
going into retirement an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses and
everything else goes on your home until
your home is paid for
yeah we are doing fifteen percent now we
just need but you're not you have not
put all the money in on your house on
baby step six
right the question i get i got that
i got that and i've answered the
question
okay now do you want to know you want to
know why
here's why okay
this idea that you can get rich keeping
a mortgage
there's no data points that indicate
that
77
of the millionaires that we studied had
a paid off house
interesting they didn't dump it on the
stock market because they thought they
could make more
they didn't dump it all mutual funds
because they thought they could make
more they put a healthy amount in mutual
funds because the typical millionaire
when we find them the first area they
hit is about a third of their net worth
is their paid off home about 500 000 and
then there's about a million over there
in their mutual funds you are not old
you have plenty of time if you never do
anything but 15
at your age and your income you're going
to be worth 10 million dollars just
doing that if you never do anything else
and you just burn the rest of the money
in the middle of the front yard you're
mathematically going to be okay
so quit trying to fix this it's not
broken kiddo dump that money on the
house get your stinking house paid off
fast as you can and that's the fastest
route between where you are and wealth
is that's what we teach now if you want
to do something else you're welcome too
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney my co-host today opened
phones on the ramsey show in the lobby
of ramsey solutions on the debt free
stage ethan and whitney are with us hey
guys how are you you're fantastic how
are you better than i deserve brother
where are you guys from
we are from louisville mississippi uh
about 30 minutes from the gulf coast ah
l.a lower alabama
i like it cool welcome brother good to
have you guys how much debt have y'all
paid off 56
761 dollars and five cents not that
we're counting right right
how long did that take you 36 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time started at 34 000 went
up to 70 000. whoa
okay what do you guys do for a living
i'm a stay-at-home mom
and at the start of this journey i was a
science teacher soccer coach went from
that to a fitness instructor and then i
got furloughed and became a truck driver
oh wow yes and that's how we go from 34
to 70 and double our income that's it
wow a little bit of everything you're
not afraid of work no i'm jack of all
trades yeah i'm telling you very cool
what kind of debt was the 57 000 it was
all student loans all right
good for you so uh what are the degrees
in
my degree is in a bachelor science
exercise science
it was all his student loans
all right so what happened three years
ago put you guys on this journey
well
we started
when i was 20 i heard about you from a
co-worker
and we were engaged at the time so he
jumped on board we took fbu when we got
married
unfortunately we failed the class we
were ish for a while oh no
yes and ish is a wish so it didn't work
that's right and can't half butt do this
stuff that's right all right yeah i
realized ish wasn't working and
i was pregnant with my fourth
baby
and i knew we had all these student
loans
piled up and
i didn't even know the balance of it
that's how ish we were
but i looked i thought i had an idea and
when i checked the balance it was over
fifty thousand
and he took out thirty eight thousand so
i was a little scared yeah
this is going the wrong way that's right
it's great
that
is what fired me up and i said no more
we're doing gazelle intense we're i've
printed out all the charts
we did the debt snowball it was eight
total loans we did from smallest to
largest he came home from work and saw
all the stuff i printed out and put up
on the wall and we made chains out for
the kids every time we did a certain
amount they broke a chain off
so
ethan you came home and your wife had
gone crazy yes yes and what did you say
said i better be ready to eat some beans
and rice rice and beans
i knew real quick what i was about to be
into
she seems
whitney you seem like somebody who is so
lovely and easy going
but when that switch flips it is
you knew didn't you that's right it's
gonna happen yeah hey so i got an
identity question for you so ethan
when you're a teacher
you're a teacher right and then when
you're a fitness person you're a fitness
person
how have you been able to toggle these i
those are two significant lifelong
identities right and here you are
you know what i'm a double income i'm
gonna keep putting food on my table in
the middle of a pandemic i'll become a
trucker i'll do whatever it takes how
did you do that
but
i just knew that uh when i got
furloughed and i was just trying to just
go survival mode during that time
and uh
i just i wasn't hearing anything i was
supposed to only be furloughed for about
six weeks wasn't hearing anything
um so i was like i've got to do
something i'm tired of having this debt
on me this was all my debt
so
i'll be the one to go do something and
i was looking into the cdl i saw that
you'd go to school for a couple of weeks
uh get your license and then you can
immediately go work over the road and
just make a lot of money
so i was like i won't do it
so whitney got on board with me
got done with it real quick and um
it was rough at first because you know i
always like to run i like to exercise
i'm just stuck in a truck
i made it work out for me i kept my
exercise stuff with me i'm that weird
guy that would be at a rest area just
running
at different places but um
i knew that it was going to be
worthwhile
just getting out of this debt
that's incredible what's your long-term
goal
well i'm actually i'm starting to look
into personal training again i am
enjoying driving a truck um
i'll keep doing it but i would love to
just go back into personal training uh
make sure i wouldn't put any debt or
anything
with that of course but uh see if i can
start getting clientele again and just
get back to what i love okay are you
still driving over the road or i'm
actually i'm i'm local now so once we
got out here so you're home at night i'm
home every night now okay
uh so i get to see the kids spend
quality time with them and still making
good money yeah absolutely you are well
done well i love it you're willing to do
whatever it takes for your family that's
for yourself on the short term and then
we start looking at the long term figure
out what we're going to do and now you
don't need that how does that feel
great don't have this burden over our
shoulders yeah what do you tell people
the secret to getting out of debt is for
me it's contentment you see your friends
going and doing things and you have to
tell yourself no you have to tell the
kids no
so i would say contentment yes
mine was every day think about the end
goal
say how you're gonna get there even if
you knew it's gonna be hard but you take
it one day at a time
pushing through you guys are incredible
yeah i just i hope everybody listening
to this the millions of people listening
this here
it's so easy to get trapped into an
identity and i'm a this person and we
attach that to our work and you've on
multiple occasions said i'm the kind of
guy that takes care of his wife and kids
i'm the kind of guy that's not scared of
hard work i'm a guy that can reinvent
myself and go jogging at a truck stop
while my buddies are all eating chicken
fingers for breakfast good for you my
man what an absolute stud thank you
absolutely i agree heroes you took
control of your life and you can't and
then that gives you options to readjust
from there and do whatever you want to
do you can choose to continue to drive a
truck or you can choose to do something
else and that's nothing no shame in
either one of those by the way that's
right that's awesome awesome this
willingness to
it's both of those are a type of
contentment really both of you um where
you just said whatever whatever it takes
whatever it takes let's do it we'll pay
the price because it's worth it now was
it worth it
yes
look at your smiles it's unbelievable
man that's very wow and you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages yes have them get up in the shot
okay we have
hayden
is six aj is seven mm-hmm eli is four
addie is three all right that's pretty
much just rocking the mullet baby it
looks great
very well done good stuff well we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you that
is your next chapter in your story to
become baby steps millionaires
completely change this whole family tree
which you're in the process of doing so
proud of y'all
very very well done we got a copy total
money makeover for you to give away to
somebody and help them out and you can
pay it forward a little bit as well
so show someone else how to do what you
guys have done and just remind them not
to do ish huh that's right this is a
wish i love it ethan and whitney a.j
hayden eli and addy 57 000
paid off in 36 months making 34-70 doing
whatever it takes to win count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream are you
ready three two one
i
love it
well done you guys
very very well done you can tell by the
volume of a couple of those kids they
are done with rice and beans steve
they want a hamburger well they like
celebrating and we we tore off enough of
those uh
cardboard
links off that chain where our family's
free that's exactly right and you can
remember that when you're six and you
can remember that when you're five and
you remember that when you're eight it's
very possible you'll remember the day
mom and daddy changed our lives and one
of them's gonna come in and say hey dad
i got accepted to such college but i'm
gonna need to take out a student loan
and he's gonna remember her look that
she gave him that one day
he's gonna say no son i don't think
that's gonna happen i don't think that's
going to occur young man
amazing i
love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
55 percent of americans want to change
jobs this year the struggle with burnout
is
real the struggle with existential
crisis is real
we've even given this a name the great
resignation it is called
uh but just like you need a plan for
your money you absolutely need a plan
for your career ask yourself what do i
like about my current job what do i not
like about my current job what does my
dream job look like and what do i need
to do in order to have my dream job if
it's time to make a change america's
career coach ken coleman has written out
his proven career plan in this brand new
book from paycheck to purpose
stop settling for just another paycheck
and find the work that brings purpose
and joy into your life the book plus the
100 in free tools because it's in
pre-sale we'll send you for pre-ordering
uh will help you find out what you're
meant to do who you're meant to be where
your dream job is everyone needs to read
this book before changing jobs
don't just go chasing something that's
going to get you in trouble get your
copy from paycheck to purpose today at
ramseysolutions.com
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
today's question comes from regina in
kentucky regina writes my husband's 86
year old father moved in with us after
his wife passed away
at the time he had over two million
dollars in retirement investments two
years ago he met a woman who's 54. he
has spent well over 800 thousand dollars
on her nothing his children say will
deter him from pulling money out of his
investments to make her happy when we
talk to him about this he says if he
runs out of money we'll just have to
provide for him my husband and i did not
sacrifice to build our retirement just
to support a lovesick old man
what is the family obligation
to support aging family members can i
just divorce my father-in-law
you know what dave i've been doing this
a long time i've never heard that wow
can i divorce my father-in-law a
love-sick old man
she is over this can you tell
dave what do you think about this
about her i think she's pissed i i know
she is yeah yeah um
yeah it's pretty obvious just see the
the the email has heat on it yeah i just
set it down it burns
um
this reminds me of an inverse problem
and i don't i don't have a ton of
experience with
um 86 you know 8788 what we call
geriatric older folks
family members
i always i i know that there is a
i feel a responsibility if you will to
to love and support my parents as best i
can the other side of this is it reminds
me of an old henry cloud statement when
you're talking about young kids which is
uh if he's 15 and he was acting like
this henry would say dr clyde would say
he needs some problems
and the 86 year old who is taking
advantage of his children at this point
and just burning through his money which
he's allowed to do it's his money but he
also has no repercussion for it because
he feels like he's got a safety net so
at some point
it feels like the his kids can
make a make set their boundaries and
then dad with his
1.2 million dollars left gets to make
some of his own decisions
what do you think about that
it sounds fardy feels harsh just saying
that out loud too um no here's the thing
i i
think that we're
called to take care of our family i
agree but we need to define
take care of our family right the
problem with enablers is is that they
and she's not
but uh the problem with enablers is is
that they define help improperly
they provide help as being nice and
allowing people to continue in the risk
behavior that's not actually helping
this man correct this man has another
problem okay we everyone hearing this
story through this lady's eyes anyway uh
is really confirmed that this 54 year
old is not attracted to this 86 year old
she's attracted to his money right she's
a gold digger
um he's well aware his birthday suit
needs earning okay i mean this is this
is not an attraction this is a money
thing it's a money play and um so
you know he's being taken advantage of
are you helping him
by winking and nodding at it
that's enabling i don't think you're
helping him right so i think you got to
love him not be disgusted love him
enough to not be disgusted with him
she's pretty angry but gently and kindly
just say dad
there are some consequences
of your misbehavior right
because this lady's not after you
she's taking advantage of you everyone
that loves you is telling you that and
you technically have a right to be
stupid that's not illegal it's your
money it's your money but you can't live
here yeah while you're doing it we're
not going to condone it and you need to
go ahead and be on notice that we do not
feel obligated to take care of you
as if you weren't didn't burn through
two million dollars
by giving it to a gold digger and so dad
um if you're going to continue to give
her money you can't stay here
and you cannot expect future help from
us now if you're hungry you can come
over and have dinner
we're not gonna allow you to be hungry
you're not gonna you know but we are not
obligated to support you
while you're doing cocaine right
i always just kind of one of the things
i do in my head if i think i'm being an
enabler because i really people think
i'm just a smart out like which i am but
they they also you know but i got this
huge heart and i have a real tendency to
participate in people's insanity just
keep going and going i don't know i
think most people do most of us that
love people you know we have a tendency
to do that and i just extrapolate it to
something extreme
and say if he was doing cocaine would
you allow him to stay in your house
right no well all that is is another
form of misbehavior
if he was you know if he was boiling
crack in the back bedroom
you know would you allow him to stay
here that's another form of misbehavior
but that's kind of taking it crazy but
that helps you think about
even though this this is a little more
socially acceptable
than boiling crack in the back bedroom
yeah right and so
um you do you do boil correct now i
really didn't make it i'm gonna let it
rise i'm literally cooking crack i
didn't want it i didn't want to drop my
my crack knowledge here okay all right
in the middle of the in the middle of my
uh soliloquy but
you'll mess up my poetry but um but yeah
that's uh can i tell you some heat that
i think i feel on this yeah and this is
since regina's not here i think she's
been mad a long time she's been mad a
long time she's mad at her husband for
not stepping in the middle of this and
this is hard
but when you have an 86 year old in your
home with this kind of money it's easy
to start spinning it in your head it's
easy to start thinking man just when he
so and so passes away we'll be able to
get this and we'll be able to take care
of that
and to see it just liquidating on
somebody who
you think has ulterior motives oh well
we all do it just i think i think
i mean i i just i don't think there's
any question about that but yeah yeah
you need to check your own heart and
make sure what you're really he's got to
do what he wants to do with his money
and but he's not allowed to live in my
house but you've got to draw boundaries
yeah and i'm not required
by moral standards to take care of
someone's misbehavior i'm required to
honor my father and mother which means i
honor the office
of father i'm required to honor
the president
we've had several presidents in the last
few years that i agreed with almost
nothing any of them did right but that
doesn't mean i'm going to dishonor the
office of the of the president of the
united states i can i don't have to
dishonor the office of father
but i can dishonor his behavior there
you go i can disagree with the
president's behavior you can draw
boundaries and go that's out of control
you're acting like an alzheimer's
patient quit that you know i'm not going
to take take direction from you uh
and so and this is important you all
have already talked to him you've done
the right thing you sat down and talked
to him he said i don't care yeah she's
more important than you all are yeah go
live with her
and see how long you get to stay after
you run out of money
not very long yeah about 20 seconds
oh man that's so sad that is
heartbreaking but yeah you are gonna
have to move him out um and your
husband's going to be the one that does
it and your husband's going to stack up
step up and get a backbone and deal with
this because you're going to end up
really further pissed at him if you
don't yeah you're going to end up losing
your marriage over this you all got to
be on the same page right here yeah and
it feels like
you feel yeah i i think while your
husband's gone up to about a three boil
you boiled over she's over
and
uh
and you know
you're gonna end up thinking you can
deal with this and it's not it's not in
your
purview to deal with his dad no because
what happens is is his dad's gonna go
away and pass away and then you're gonna
have to lose your husband because you
kicked my dad out yeah and um you're
gonna have a whole other set of mess
right yeah a you got to be together
there's a different script that's going
to play then it's exactly right so
everybody's got to get on the same page
wow
yuck man yup yup there we go
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country to find a
station near you head to thermsyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money it is a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
dr john delony ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions here again about your life and
your money if you haven't tuned into the
dr john dolone show you should most of
america is now it is a ragingly popular
podcast comes out three times a week
these days you can call in and be a part
of the podcast if you'd like we'd love
to have you do that and be one of the
callers on his show if you've got
questions about relationships about
boundaries about life you can email us
at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com or leave a voicemail
at 844-693-3291
sue starts off this hour in greenville
south carolina hi sue welcome to the
ramsay show
hey thanks so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um so i'm a 57 year old
veteran and i'm single and i've been
debt-free for six years now i own my
home free and clear
um i came down to this area to be closer
to my mom she since passed away now i
want to move up north to be closer to my
son
and um the cost of living and housing is
more expensive up there
and i was saving money um
to buy a farm but decided i can't do
that so i've got i've got a chunk of
cash that i can put to a house up where
i want to go and then i could take the
cash out of this house
um and and
you know do a cash purchase or i could
get a mortgage and rent this house out
down here i'm trying to figure out what
the best thing would be to do
what do you do for a living
i'm a disabled vet so i i helped i
helped some young farmers in in our area
but your income that you eat with is
disability income from the veterans
incorrect yeah military retirement yeah
well thank you thank you for your
service and i'm sorry you were hurt my
pleasure yeah my pleasure you you're
going up to see your son
but it sounds like you love
farming and you love working with
mentoring young farmers
is that is that a worthy trade here
i love i love growing yeah what i've
discovered like farming um in the heat
of the summer is very challenging i like
starting seeds so i i want to shift to
working more like with nurseries plant
nurseries and native plants and
butterflies can you do that if you where
is up north what's that mean where are
you going uh um the chicago area
yeah
are you gonna are you gonna plug into
the agricultural scene
out away from chicago but in that
general area i was going to stay closer
to the city and do do more like the
place of the plant plant nurseries
versus actual farming farming yeah
something more more more toward my
abilities
here's the easy answer to your question
is what you called for and that is sell
the house in greenville pay cash for the
house that you moved to in chicago okay
okay now here's why i reverse engineer
these questions
in my mind and it gives me the answer
instantly and i'll teach you the
technique and that way you can do it
next time if you owned a paid for house
in chicago to be near your son
would you suddenly jump up and go buy a
rental in greenville south carolina with
debt
no see it's the same thing but in
reverse
right
and so it tells me not to keep the house
in greenville you're becoming a
greenville investor by default not by
strategy
right well the only thing is i could i
could it could be a source of income it
doesn't change anything you still
answered no
right right and you answered no because
it was wise to answer no
you instantly do not think about it you
just went no i wouldn't buy a rental
house in greenville south carolina if i
freaking live in chicago no
some idiot changes hardly in your living
room floor you know no
you can't manage property four or five
hundred six hundred miles away
adequately yeah yeah
my only other concern is that well it's
cold up there i mean i grew up in maine
but it's cold up there and and all my
friends down here like well you could
you could keep the keep the other house
and and you can also come down there and
visit when you don't have a house
yeah this is true right oh rent you a
bnb for three weeks with what used to be
a house payment
right and you changed the oil to your
harley in their living room
it works way better that way
it's a better breakout ramona's in
seattle hi ramona welcome to the ramsay
show
hello
hi how can we help i had a
yes i'm at a loss i lost my brother um
three weeks ago
he was 27
very unexpected um
and i don't he has no kids no marriage
no will he lived with me
what do i do with
his debt and what do i do with this
asset everyone keeps telling me to get a
probate lawyer
my dad i'm trying to help my dad and my
mom out my mom has put it all on me
because i took care of him
and
my dad he wants to push everything to
the side and just says
he's grieving and he doesn't want to
deal with it and
he he he doesn't know how to move
forward and so i'm trying to he owes the
irs he has
you know all these steps and stuff and
what what do i do when do i when do we
get this ball rolling on taking care of
dave
i'm so sorry what a mess
why were you having to take care of him
what was wrong with him
um a lot so he um a lot of medical
problems um
he had type 1 diabetes with adrenal
deficiency which
played a big role he had intestine
problems um
also
mental problems so it was just a lot of
brain damage um
you know we found him um
i left the house
came back a few hours later and i found
him um from home with no pulse
he uh his blood sugar went too low had a
seizure and he um
died from there i'm so sorry
you really
really really
did everything you could to take care of
your brother what a great sister
i'm so sorry
so my guess is with what you're
describing to me that he did not own
anything
no asset just like
just like real two vehicles and do they
have their payments on them
no
okay what are they worth
um
nothing
okay they're not worth anything okay
no they're probably worth almost a
thousand dollars yeah
and so he and and all so all he has is
debts
correct okay
all right um
for your sanity and the sanity of your
dad
um i want to clear these debts off so
they don't pester you
you do not owe them your dad does not
owe them your mom does not owe them
they're not going to get paid
because he didn't have any money
when you pass away what you own stands
good for what you owe
so get a copy of his death certificate
and send copies of the death certificate
to the irs and any other debtors you're
aware of with a letter that says
uh my brother so and so passed away on
such such a date here's the death
certificate he did not have any assets
you will not be paid
and it's just that simple you don't need
a probate lawyer you don't need anything
because there's nobody there's nothing
to collect there's nothing to collect it
from
yeah and ramona
often when we walk in and see the
situation that you saw i'm so sorry that
you saw that i want you to know it's not
your fault
your brother was lucky to have you in
his life taking care of him and loving
him the way you did
and you're gonna need to get somebody to
walk alongside you yeah get with a good
pastor and unpack some of this you're
hurting kiddo
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two
how many times in the past year have you
heard someone say i just wish things
would get back to normal well i kind of
think we all think that but what was
normal like for you was it really that
good
are you worried about money uh
too much to do not enough time to do it
all
well you shouldn't have to go back to
that normal hey there's a better idea we
want to help you with a game plan
and uh that's tomorrow night september
the 28th game plan live our free live
stream it's me christy wright and george
campbell we're going to be talking about
your time
about goal setting and about your money
and laying out a clear game plan to make
sure those goals happen and uh let's
have a vision for your life let's do
some stuff here you can have the
abundant balanced debt free life you
want and it starts with game plan live a
free live stream from our own auditorium
here tomorrow night right here in the
ramsey headquarters we've got about 300
folks attending the uh the live stream
already and if you want to attend online
all you have to do is text
game plan to 33 789 it is free a free
live stream september the 28th tomorrow
night all one word 33 789 text game plan
we would love to have you join us and be
part of that
dr john delony ramsey personality is my
co-host today best-selling author anna
is in st louis hi anna welcome to the
ramsey show
anna hello hello hi how are you
i'm doing well how are you dave good how
can i help
so i have a question regarding um so my
husband and i are in baby step 3b
and my husband works in
commission-based jobs so we don't have
any
credit score so in order for us to get
underwritten for our home loan we have
to wait two years so we're gonna have to
wait two years to get a
home loan
to qualify for our home with churchill
mortgage
a couple of days ago my father-in-law
and my mother-in-law who are in baby
step 7
offered to
purchase a house and get
and let us rent to own it from them and
i have been
thinking about it and wondering what if
that's a good idea or uh if that's
something that's better not to just
not worry about
yeah
how old are you guys
uh 27-28 man what's your household
income
about 3 000 a month
3 000 a month
okay
um
what does your husband do
he's a plumber okay that's good news
okay
and has his income been going up
good he's still on an apprenticeship
yeah when will he finish that
uh i think he can get his journeyman
after four years
okay
okay um
this is the kind of deal
that makes sense mathematically and is a
relational
minefield
if you miss a payment
you might go sideways
and have a weird thanksgiving dinner
as a matter of fact you might
really have a high potential for a weird
thanksgiving dinner
um
and so i um i tell parents not to loan
their kids money
grown kids
and um and i tell people not to let me
tell you the borrower's slave to the
lender
and when you eat thanksgiving dinner
with your master
the turkey tastes different
and so i would tell you not to do this
on that basis instead use that two years
to save money
and get your income stabilized and get
his income up
i think your in-laws are not bad people
i think they're very generous they're
being kind they're trying to be trying
to get their grandbaby that i hear in
the background into a house i appreciate
that out of them and they're probably
not bad people they're probably not
toxic and controlling or something like
that or you wouldn't be considering this
but
um i i just am not i don't want you to
be susceptible to that i tell people not
to do this because i've seen more of it
go sideways than not what are you
thinking john i'm thinking
under no circumstances whatsoever should
you do this and i wasn't even thinking
about thanksgiving i was thinking about
that little baby you're holding
and when mother-in-law says well you
know you should be
that's a lot different when she owns
your mortgage
and suddenly that baby's got two moms
two dads
and can i be honest with you
absolutely it sounds like you knew the
answer call i could hear your voice does
your husband want to do this and you
don't
we're
i think you're right i think we kind of
knew we listened to
dave and dr d a lot so we kind
of knew the answer but needed someone to
tell us the answer
yeah i i i'm a thousand percent with
dave your autonomy here y'all are
grinding it he's working hard you're
working hard you're young you got time
yeah get an apartment get a two-bedroom
apartment and y'all make it work for the
next two years and save save save save
save
and um every
yeah it sounds so good mathematically
dave's right but it's not a good move
yeah i i just
the the problem is of 30 years of doing
this i've seen
i'm like a cancer doctor i see what
causes cancer yeah you know and it's
like you know you can do that if you
want but a lot of people i've seen with
cancer had that you know it's like that
kind of a thing right and so that that's
kind of what this falls into can you get
away with it yeah you can get away with
it
i remember when we went broke sharon's
dad
uh
went to the bank and got a loan as if he
didn't have the money in a coffee can in
the backyard probably but um and uh to
help us save the house out of bankruptcy
and so we owed him some money um
and had to pay the payments to pay that
loan off after bankruptcy
and um he is
one of the sweetest kindest men
i've ever known he is just a great guy
and he never said
didn't even wrinkle an eyebrow
never one little bit of voice inflection
nothing never said a negative word one
time
but i man my butt was on fire yeah i was
driving me nuts of course i just gone
broke too so that's added to it right
but um but i'm like this is killing me i
can't i walked in his house i felt
different
it was just weird well that's that's the
thing if you don't acknowledge that yeah
that's just then you're just dumb you
can't calculate what those
oh is that the is that the shirt he's
wearing to church sounds different when
she owns your mortgage yeah or hey you
all are only going to stay for two days
for christmas sounds different when he
owns your mortgage it's just everything
beca it's like a domino of emotions and
feelings and all that stuff yeah
and it's bad enough when you got a brand
new baby
there's all that's there anyway
but then on top of that
yeah let's just go ahead and put in
there
that they
but it's so tempting and
you said it best dave those parents are
they are loving those kids that's what
they don't know how i got nothing in her
conversation that said they were that
they're oh that they're all three
but they're off the rails yeah nothing
at all open phones triple eight eight
two five five two two five eduardo is in
los angeles hi eduardo how are you
hi dave thank you for taking my phone
sure what's up
yes uh my question dave i have for you
today is that
um i
have my one thousand dollar deductible
uh down payment
um
for the card i recently had a collision
and um
i'm alright but uh
i'm following the baby steps and
i kind of want to know your thoughts on
if i should parents pause i was paying
some credit card debt
and so how much damage was there to the
car
um so i do i do have a
estimate and it says around
1 000
or
100
1100
okay and you have a 1 dollar deductible
yeah one thousand dollar deductible so
you're turning it into insurance
benefits you buy a hundred dollars
yeah it sounds like the car is very
drivable to me
yeah it is very reliable still
drivable
after the wreck you can drive it without
fixing it right
yeah yeah drive it
you don't need to pay fix a thousand
dollar repair with a thousand dollar
deductible don't turn that into
insurance
yeah i mean yes drive it and keep keep
getting your debt paid off brother yeah
plow through brother grind hustle grind
hustle grind hustle sorry you got in the
wreck yeah this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience
if someone from that company likes your
profile they can personally invite you
to apply for the job so if you're ready
for an easier job search check out
ziprecruiter sign up for free right now
at ziprecruiter.com ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today you can hear him
every couple of days on a brand new
podcast comes out three times a week
called the dr john deloney show you
should tune into it most of america is
these days in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage craig
and rachel are with us hey guys hey
how's it going great how are you where
do you live we are from central michigan
all right very cool welcome to nashville
and how much data have you guys paid off
we paid off 55 000.
cool how long did that take
um just shy of two years 23 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time
50 and then we ended just over 70. cool
what do y'all do for a living
i work in customer service in the waste
and recycling industry
and i'm a sales manager at our local
radio station oh good for you yeah very
cool
good old radio love it gotta love it
it's a great world yeah it's been a wild
world this year it has craziness i was
gonna draw a parallel between uh waste
management and the radio world but i
won't do that since we're on the radio
we already know so
we get it
very cool what kind of debt was the 55
000. mainly my student loans um a couple
cars couple credit cards
some student loans we were normal yeah
how long y'all been married
five years we actually uh so
about 35 months prior to making our last
payment we started and uh
two or three weeks into the journey we
found out that we were pregnant with our
first our first child so
everything got put on pause there for a
little while and so that's why our
journey's really only about 23 months
okay very good very cool so what made
you guys decide to get serious about
this get out of debt thing
we had always kind of been on a budget
but not a dave budget by any means um
and we knew we wanted to start a family
and so we were like all right we gotta
get serious we gotta start this process
um and then three weeks into it we
really had to get serious um
so just she's our why um
moving forward yeah and to be honest you
know
for me what it was was hearing you talk
about changing your family tree and your
legacy
with us starting it was like okay she's
gonna drag me along i'm definitely the
spender anybody that knows us knows that
um i'm the spender i'm the free spirit
and uh so we started i was excited and
then three weeks in we obviously got the
news and so
that message of changing your family
tree really hit me in a different way
and it was like all right it's time to
to get really serious about this
there's something magical happens when
the first baby comes
there is game oh
there it is for sure
yeah i hear you well congratulations you
guys yeah thank you so who had the
conversation with who
well
well i started um friends of ours chris
and kendra actually sat down and helped
me write our first budget and i was like
we're starting it's gonna happen we're
just going to start and then he started
listening to your show
every day every hour like got crazy
then we were both on board and there was
no stopping at that point are we on one
of your stations
uh unfortunately i'm on the competitor
as of right now
okay there's actually
not really any local stations
are carrying you oh my gosh they're a
little ways away but but we definitely
tuned in we tuned in on youtube and on
the podcast and all any way we could we
did and uh before long we were driving
some dave cars and
um
probably my biggest struggle throughout
this whole thing was wanting to get a
new lawnmower we we purchased a new
house
before we were on the plan and it's got
some acreage and we we wanted to well i
wanted to get a new zero turn mower sure
you know you know the whole thing and uh
instead i'm driving a 1986 lawnmower
around and um that's our
that's our form of entertainment there's
a picture of it on youtube i love it it
doesn't even have the hood on it it
doesn't have the hood i like it but the
girls in the wagon and we go for a drive
that's uh that's how we have fun in
michigan that's a manly lawnmower right
there there's our dave track yeah that's
for sure yes
i love it
wow wow wow wow you guys are very well
done y'all weren't making a million
dollars y'all didn't mess around this
was a hard year and a half for you guys
it was we were very blessed um to keep
our jobs through everything that
happened and we
student loans went on and
zero interest and everything was put on
hold and we said this is our chance this
is our blessing this is our time to just
start throwing everything we've got at
it so the last
nine or ten months we actually paid off
20 000 of it whoa
game on i've got to tell you guys that
uh this may we celebrated our fifth
anniversary and we had an elaborate trip
planned for the weekend and instead of
going on that trip we decided let's take
the money that we would have spent
because it's pretty close to what our
last payment is let's just pay off our
debt and so we actually on our fifth
wedding anniversary we made our final
payment submit yeah ding ding
dong
submitted our last and celebrated and it
was great yeah so that means you've had
several months of
that both checks depositing and no bills
feels good huh it's been wonderful
that's cool what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt ish um for me
i was the one to actually write the
budgets each month and there were so
many times in the middle
where it's not like the beginning fun
exciting point and you're not in the
home stretch yet and there's so many
times where you're like
i don't want to do another month i don't
want to do another month something hits
life hits and you're like
it's not working but just keep writing
the budgets keep doing it stay
consistent
and just keep moving it's the grind it
is it is for me i would say just listen
to your wife and and do as she says
no i think uh just finding that why and
it's gonna change multiple times
regardless of how long your journey is
everybody's on a different journey and
you know whether you make a million
dollars or you make ten dollars it's
it's all
relative and you just have to
focus on your journey and put your head
down and stick with it yeah well done
guys i'm proud of you
good stuff man
well done good good good good good
wow who were your biggest cheerleaders
outside the two of you
so my mom and stepdad are actually here
with us they were a huge support through
the whole thing um
they've been listening to you forever my
brother and sister-in-law they were kind
of our go-to for calling and what should
we do here
um yeah with friends my parents also
were big cheerleaders and then uh really
my whole family but our friends chris
and kendra that walked us through it and
kendra actually led our fpu class and
then our friends tori oh you went
through financial pictures
at nine months pregnant
and our friends tori and shauna gave us
uh gave us your book to get us started
and so they they were there alongside of
us the whole way very cool well way to
go heroes thank you
how's it feel to be free
amazing so good yeah good for you
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's definitely the uh next uh
chapter in your story without a doubt
can bring a little bailey up here and
bring bailey into the shot here we got
to have the the proper why in the in the
picture this is a beautiful one look at
her wow she's cute as a button we have
bailey and we have number two on the way
yay
i love it congratulations you've also
got an extra copy of total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody pay it forward and keep this
stuff rolling just keep getting people
keep getting america out of debt so they
can be wealthy so proud of you guys well
well done all right craig rachel and
bailey lansing michigan 55 000 paid off
in 23 months and had a baby look at that
girl oh my goodness 50 to 70 000. count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Laughter]
i love it
congratulations you guys very very well
done that's impressive ah that's hey i
don't want to blow by the math on this
they've rice and beans to this one yeah
i mean that that was a rough ride that's
a tight turnaround man and uh and they
you know they did some of it they're
piling up cash while she's pregnant what
you're supposed to do while pushing
pause and then throw it on the debt push
play when the baby comes home mama's
okay
rock on through this grind through it
push it through
both of our debt-free screams on this
particular day have been modest incomes
and amazing amounts of debt which means
amazing amounts of sacrifice but they
did have a 1986 lawn mower to help to
help ease the pain right i'm just saying
that lawn mower
that's a manly lawnmower incredible this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
dr chondaloni ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
john is with us in cincinnati hey john
how are you
i'm doing well thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
i've got a capital gains question
my wife and i are preparing to sell our
home we didn't want to reinvest right
away in another home we kind of wanted
to
do a little bit of traveling first
is there a time frame
that we have to work within
you're over 40 aren't you
yeah i'm definitely over 40. yeah that's
an old law that law hasn't been on the
books in a long time the law for the
last 20 years or so has been um that
your
personal
residence when you sell it if you've
owned it more than two years has zero
taxes on the first five hundred thousand
dollars of gain if you're married filing
jointly are you going to have a gain
greater than a half million
no dollars would be under that then
there'll be zero taxes regardless of
what you do with the money or when you
reinvest you don't have any limitations
awesome
that is perfect i i really appreciate it
now verify that with your tax
professional but you'll find i'm right
it's one of the few tax laws that i
actually do know and understand most of
them i don't i'm horrible at when did
that change
it's probably about 20 years ago well it
used to be you had two years to buy
another house they rolled it back in and
but you're you're over 40. yeah i bought
my first house 20 years ago wow that's
what i knew yeah i mean that was the law
of forever and that was a big change
because now your home largely grows
taxes free
if you sell it after you owned it a
couple of years you don't have any taxes
on the first half million married filing
jointly first quarter million as a
single
and uh so like one of our good friends
sold his house not long ago made like
160 grand on it a guy that was working
here a little while back and he owned it
uh
like two years in a day and paid zero
taxes
so conceivably you could sell your house
every couple years and continue to move
up and i guess once you don't get that i
would assume you're not married
because moving every two years would
cause other issues uh at least at my
house it would d is with us d's in
detroit michigan hi dee how are you
i'm doing great how about yourself
better than i deserve how can we help
okay um i am retired i'm a widow and i'm
debt-free
and my problem is that my house needs
some updates and repairs i've been
getting estimates the estimates uh seem
like everything is uh three four five
times what i expected to pay
um and what i'm looking at is i'm
looking at getting a line of credit to
do the repairs and and the labor labor
saving updates because i'm 63
versus um using my savings but i i
wasn't going to go beyond what i have to
you know that like what if i was going
to pay cash for
so i what i wanted i just wanted to get
some advice from you
um do you think that's a good idea
uh do you advise something else or what
but you know the house needs to be
updated how much in repairs is the total
oh
probably about 50 60 000
and how much money do you have in your
total world
well i got more than 60 how much money
do you have in your total world
in my total world i have 500 000.
okay
dee you have done a really good job
fix your house with your money
use money and fix your house don't use
debt and fix your house
not a line of credit nope why would i
put you back in debt you're my friend
well because i'd rather have my money
working for me it's not working for you
you're paying the bank you're paying the
bank well okay we'll see there's another
caveat uh problem is um
i always have to pay taxes every year
and if i took a line of credit
i was thinking that that would help
reduce
if you want to if you want to do that
all you have to do is give more to your
church
gardening you give more to your church
you'll have the exact same mathematical
effect you don't go in debt
if you want to if you want to lower your
tax bill increase your charitable giving
well i've been doing that same thing
listen if you give the bank ten thousand
dollars which you're not going to if you
give the bank a thousand dollars in
interest
okay
you know what it saves you in taxes
no 200
really yep
tax deduction is not a tax credit it's a
deduction and so it reduces your income
that is taxable by one thousand dollars
as applied to your tax rate and in your
situation the way you're the way you're
structured in the way your life's set up
you're probably have an effective tax
rate of around twenty percent maybe it's
thirty percent but it saves you two to
three hundred dollars the other seven
hundred dollars is just burned you
didn't make a thousand by giving them a
thousand so you gave them a thousand to
say to not give the government 200.
i don't want you doing that if you want
to do that give your church an extra
thousand that way you don't have to give
the government 200.
and you don't even have to be in debt to
do that one
okay um is there a way that i if
somebody told me that if i if
hey d you're listening to a lot of
stupid people
yeah
who are you i don't know who's in your
ear but they're dumber than a rock
i don't know who this is you don't need
to incorporate you're a 64 year old
widow trying to fix her house
you got 500 thousand yeah 500 000 fix
your freaking house
just fix it and then i don't have any
nightmares and if you want to turn a
thousand dollars into a 200 tax
deduction just increase your charitable
giving by that you don't have to be in
debt for that it's the exact same
ratio
here's a promise i'll make you d if you
mail
um a thousand dollars to ramsey
solutions here in nashville i will mail
you two hundred dollars
that's a that's a personal promise
if you want to make that trade john
deloney has a system to do it i will in
fact this isn't just for you dee this is
for anyone in america
a thousand dollars to the ramsey
solutions building you're gonna get me
arrested
personally mail you 200 cash
ramsey sets up pyramid scheme john
deloney at the tip i'm i'm happy to
all day this crap is going to get this
is not going to go well some liberal
left-wing newspapers are going to think
you're serious
because they can't do math either
oh god d-u-1 life don't pay a bank three
or four or five percent god no and call
yourself sophisticated no don't that's
sophisticated that's just stupid in fact
call it borrow call the contractor and
say i have forty thousand dollars in
cash yeah and this sixty thousand
dollars is it's not an it's it's real
money
i got 40 grand i'm gonna hand it to you
in in cash i want this work done after
it's done after of course and they're
gonna line up in front of your house
yeah yeah well not these days but yeah
it's there's a lot of people that's true
that's a labor shortage because of the
government but
anyway now that it's uh d don't go into
it honey please don't go into it you
have the money you've earned it you win
at life you did a good job pay cash for
your home repairs the other interesting
thing is on addition to all of this
stuff is that when you spend the forty
thousand dollars in cash or fifty
thousand two things will occur one john
is correct you'll get better deals
and the reason is number two you're more
careful it is interesting to me that
when all of us when we spend 100 bills
out of our checking account
we are more careful with those than we
are with borrowed money
so i had a i had a buddy uh back when i
was in college and he worked with some
home builders and he said i could always
tell the millionaires versus the middle
class people buying in this building in
this neighborhood he said it was the
millionaires who came in with the
newspaper flyer and they said uh-uh i
said i wanted this sink because it was
on sale at this place at this time and
you all put in that sink versus the
middle class buyer that came in and said
we don't know what do you think
and it was this attention to detail and
it's attention to
dollars because it's real money versus
some big loan that's right that's right
and folks never never do something for
the tax deduction you're trading you're
trading a dollar for a quarter where
does that come from
uh i hear that all the time it comes
from the real estate business okay we
used to teach people oh it's smart to be
in that because you get a tax deduction
i did that crap actually when i was 18
and stupid
when i got my real estate license you
need the tax deduction get a bigger loan
yeah trade a dollar for a quarter matter
of fact trade 100 for 25 it's even a
better deal
you don't want to pay off your home
you'll lose the tax deduction yeah one
of the things we address in fpu yes
absolutely this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios
it's the ramsey shop where that is done
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we talk about your life and
he's pretty good at that your money and
i'm pretty good at that we'll work on it
together and make sure we help you out
that's what we're here for
we are here to give you advice to help
your life better it's free and some say
the call is worth exactly what you pay
for it the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five dave is with us in santa
maria california hi dave how are you
hi i'm fine dave john thank you for
taking my call sure i'm 75. my wife is
74.
my home has paid off uh we're six
hundred thousand we have six hundred
thousand savings and
investments uh we've been debt free for
15 years
we just purchased this a half-ton pickup
to
take our rv and travel around the
country
and in closing the rv
the finance manager wanted to put a 2500
extra fee on top of
a extended warranty
i said no
and then my wife and
the finance manager both were on my case
because i wasn't gonna spend twenty five
hundred dollars for that extended
warranty
in three days the wife loves me uh but
she still kinda has a real sound joint
every now and then making a comment
about we should have got the warranty
i said i don't feel like it honey we got
the truck let's move on
uh oh you did not buy it
huh you did not buy the warranty
no i didn't you stood your ground
against the finance manager and your
wife way to go dave
you win the argument my house
yeah you win the argument my house tell
my wife yeah will you win the argument
let me tell you what to tell your wife
okay
extended warranties are a freaking scam
the finance manager would have made more
money on selling you that warranty than
selling you that truck
okay
here's the numbers
50 of that 2500 was going in that
dealership's pocket as a commission
now let's back up a second and you and i
open up an extended warranty company for
a second okay you want to go with me on
this trip let's pretend we're going to
open an extended warranty and was this
on the f-150 or on the rv
f-150 okay so what we would do if we
were going to sell extended warranties
on an f-150 which by the way is a fine
freaking truck
okay but let's just say we wanted to do
that and we would study the f-150s and
say okay out of a thousand of them the
items that we're going to cover with the
warranty break 14 times on this one and
18 times on this one and 26 times on
this one and so our cost per 1000 f150s
is x
over actual repairs does that make sense
okay if we're gonna open a warranty
company we gotta our cost of doing
business is fixing the truck right
right and we've got really good
mathematical data on the probability of
that actually occurring and what each
car costs on average to cover you wanna
know what that number is it's 12
of the 2500.
in other words out of 2500
about
280 bucks is the actual estimated
repairs of the average f-150 during the
warranty coverage
yeah well where's the rest of money
going well i told you 50 plus percent
goes to commissions and the rest of it
goes to profit for the warranty company
and or overhead for the warranty company
so you would have paid 2500 to actually
get about two hundred and eighty dollars
worth of coverage
which you should self insure through you
have six hundred thousand freaking
dollars
you are a genius you smelled a rat and
you stood up for your rights you win
your wife was looking for peace of mind
let me tell you where peace of mind
comes from 600 grand in the bank not a
warranty
rock star well done dave you got to tell
her you won the argument but be very
careful how you're telling that
it's not a matter of loving your wife i
love my wife and she's wrong sometime
did you tell her that
no
not like that i don't i see i just said
how long i've been married 39 years i'm
gonna tell her gently but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna also say you were right we
should have got the warranty because the
warranty is stupid there's scams
extended warranties are awful never buy
them people
man i i i hope both of my new dave
friends are married this time next week
they'll be great that'd be great yeah
well no i mean you got it
you got you got you got a couch how you
covered
it's hard though when you're in the
dealership the guys the dealership i was
having a cow you know why is 1250 bucks
out of his pocket well then he he did
whatever he salesmen wants to do he got
the wife involved oh yeah what a skunk
he thought he had him what a scumber man
thought he had him let me tell you you
get 600 you know how you get 600 grand
at retirement by not doing stupid i'm
not doing stupid by
smelling a rat like that oh man so i
went into an appliance store one time
with sharon we had to have a new washer
and dryer
and um
i thought the guy had recognized me the
way he was talking and it's a it's a
part of my world sometimes i recognize
sometimes i don't and it's okay either
way i'm not it's not like ego but the
way he was carrying on i thought he knew
who we were but anyway i just so we're
like i want to get have you got one with
a den in it and you know ha ha i want to
get a deal no i don't okay okay well
we'll take that one and he goes well you
need to get the extended warranty on it
and i started laughing because i thought
he knew like who it was he knew i stood
how i stood on it and he's like no no no
really you need to get this and i'm like
no no no i really don't then i start to
realize he doesn't know who i am and he
has no idea he's just trying to sell me
an extended warranty i'm like no dude i
don't i don't buy extended warranties
and then the guy goes
dave ramsey does
and i'm like why yes
and he goes yeah dave ramsey comes in
and buys stuff all the time and he
always puts an extended warranty on it
[Laughter]
i would have paid money to see you and
sharon's face right there just i'm
looking at my wife and she looks at me
and i said well i have it on good
authority that dave ramsey does not come
into this store
i am positive and by extended warranties
and he goes oh yeah i mean he bows up so
i hand him my real i pull up
i pull out my driver slices and i hand
it to him
and he goes oh
bleep
busted and starts backpedaling oh mr ed
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i said listen
dude
i said sharon we need to leave because
i'm really angry right now and this man
is using our name inappropriately and
i'm afraid i'm going to say something
that that will be a true dave ramsey
story that he can use later and we need
to leave quickly oh we'll do something
we'll fix you up man it's no problem no
problem no problem and so we left yeah
and we went to lowe's and bought them at
lowe's yep and um the next day the
manager of the store called the office
and and said can you come over here and
i went oh i said sure went over there
and he goes man we looked it up we've
got a dave ramsey on file but he lives
in another city nearby that does have
extended warranties and we've been
telling everybody it was you and we were
wrong and we've sent an email to all the
stores telling people not to do that
anymore please don't talk about us on
the radio
hey i like the fact that when he said
would you come by cause i would have
said no man i got stuff to do i like
that you said yeah i'll be right over
well this was i was having too much fun
gangster yeah yeah it's like yeah i
gotta see what this is and i went and
bought stuff from that other guy many
times after that i bought several things
from him that was my new friend that's a
good move he's my new friend
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today do you feel like you're
constantly running but nothing you do
ever moves the needle
in your money and your life
that's normal for most people normal's
frustrating exhausting
normal sucks
but you can live the life you want you
don't have to be normal
you could be debt free you could
actually have breathing room with your
schedule
and your money
but that does not happen accidentally it
takes a game plan and that's what we
want to give you we want to give you a
game plan we're doing a game plan live
stream
tomorrow night tuesday september the
28th dave ramsey me christy wright and
george campbell will help you set a
foundation that makes your goals
possible chrissy's going to talk from
her book
number one best seller take back your
time
and george is going to be talking about
goals and i'm going to walk you through
some money stuff we're going to give you
a game plan oh did i mention it's free
it's a free live stream a full-on ramsey
live event completely free don't be
normal you got to get new information if
you want new results get the plan that
gives you that gets you where you want
to be to register for a game plan live
text game plan to 33
789 you want to watch this tomorrow
night text game plan all one word to
three three
seven
eight nine
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
travis is in fort worth hi travis how
are you
i'm doing all right how about you all
better than we deserve brother how can
we help
well um
my wife and i uh both have kind of newer
cars
i paid mine off last
about probably six months ago and
she still has about 6 500
we would have had everything paid off
but we ended up both of us had a baby
last february
and
[Music]
we
don't we haven't done any payments on in
a while because we've done so many hit
payments on there and i was wanting to
know if we should
sell my vehicle to pay the rest of hers
off and then have probably about
15 000
to 20 000 left over to throw on other
stuff
are you out of debt except that
uh yes so my wife just has the 6500 that
she always left on on the 2019 uh
terrain and i got a 2017 camaro no but
you don't have any other debt anywhere
student loan debt medical debt
credit card debt
we've already paid all the hospital
bills and everything
okay so the only debt in your entire
world is six thousand five hundred
dollars
yep okay and what's your household
income
um
it's about
fifty to sixty thousand
okay
and you guys are what 24
um where she just turned 28 i'm 27 i'll
be 28 next month and you said you both
had a baby i'm assuming it's the same
kid yes okay you said that kind of funny
and i thought whoa
oh
i'm sorry
we had a new child we had a new child
yeah yeah
okay
yeah so what what i uh
all i want you to do is i want you to
get on a written
budget with our every dollar app it's
free to use
matter of fact i'll put you guys through
financial peace university
and we'll pay for it i'll pay for it and
we'll sign you up to ramsey plus
membership which will get you into
financial peace university it'll also
get you on the every dollar app premium
and the two of you you and your wife sit
down now that gift is a hundred dollar
gift if i give that to you you have to
promise me you'll use it okay
yeah we've done it before but we'll do
it again okay
um well i know you're not on a budget
because you can't tell me how much you
make
so i know you're not a written budget
every month
well yeah the reason why i'm saying i
was kind of an estimated because my wife
just started a new job and i kind of
added the numbers before then okay yeah
but your monthly income needs to be
every dollar of your monthly income
needs to be allocated to this and i want
you to roll up your sleeves do you have
any money saved other than a thousand
dollars
um
we got about probably three thousand
dollars now because she was not working
for six months but she's working on
youtube
yes okay you both have a paycheck now
you pay all your bills now take two of
the three put it on the debt that leaves
you forty five hundred you get your one
thousand dollar baby step one now we
attack that baby step two debt like it's
a debt like it's a like you're like a
gazelle running from a cheetah you
remember
and you knock it out as fast as you can
and you keep her car
yeah you don't there there's no reason
to sell your car
uh you can you can keep both of them you
need to get them paid off and then you
need to build up your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses with a
new baby in the house
and
that is the process
it's funny how the first baby especially
uh changes the landscape of the brain
right
well and he mentioned one thing that i
might consider which is he may be
walking out to that driveway and looking
at a camaro that can't fit a car seat or
something
and he wants it to be
it might make him feel noble to sell the
car for his wife but it may also be
that's an impractical it was cool when
you're a
high school kid or you're older now or
something but maybe not if you need to
sell the car for other reasons there's
nothing wrong with that right but you
don't have to sell it to get out of debt
no you make enough money pay off the car
the math the math works that's right
yeah you it may be time to
move to a family car
at this stage of the game i had a camaro
before our kids were born yeah
i'm about sharing a new camaro for
christmas before our first child was
born and then i drove it and totaled it
[Laughter]
that is the the most newlywed gift when
you get your wife something that you
really want
us a bass boat and a shotgun it's like a
kid buying a tonka truck for his mother
for mother's day yeah it's like the same
thing it was a berlinetta camaro t-tops
huh yeah yeah i totally so is it so this
is a
we've just i'm just going to derail the
show for a second okay is a corvette a
upgraded camaro
are they different cars
well they're both chevy and the
corvette's more expensive than the
camaro but so it seems like the camaro
they're not the same model i mean no but
yeah
uh you know is it like a chevy guy can
max out at him at a corvette after he
had a camaro yeah yeah i've got one okay
i guess and it's not total
it's not total to my knowledge just
sitting in the parking lot you didn't
buy it for sharon no i bought that one
for me for her birthday straight up
there's no i'm 39 years marriage i'm way
past i would have looked i've seen her
face like thanks david yeah it had a
better red bow on it i mean come on it's
like a lexus commercial
except it was a camaro it was a camaro
tricked out like i wanted exactly
man what a loving guy
what a loving guy you're a great husband
wow
this is just too much therapy on the air
greg is in phoenix hey greg how are you
i'm doing pretty well
good how can we help
well i just paid off the last of my
debts with the exception of my mortgage
my effective
yeah right
uh my effective
increase in income now is fifteen
hundred dollars
but i have not been saving for my two
kids college and since they were born uh
seven and eight years ago and
i have no idea where i should be at and
how much i should be allocating towards
that you know per month once i get
caught up to where i should be at that's
a great question at the current rate of
tuition increase you're probably gonna
want to have about 3.9 million dollars
that should get both of them through
give or take one year yeah
at a private school yeah now the uh uh
it depends on where you want to send
them to school obviously but you can get
projections on state schools
in state schools and get projections on
private
private is running about 4x to 5x of
what state schools are running right now
um and that's probably going to be true
in the future
uh i'm guessing i don't know what's
going to happen to poor higher ed but
now we tell folks after you're out of
debt you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses that's baby
step three baby step four is 15 of your
income going into retirement
okay you're well past that one you said
i'm
i'm i'm set at that as well okay then 15
of your income going into retirement is
four baby step five is kids college
money left over past that is baby step
six click smart investor pro at
ramseysolutions.com sit down with one of
the people we recommend for investing
advice
and they'll give you some exact numbers
and help you dial in what you need to be
saving for the kiddos college you're a
good dad to take care of this you're
being a grown-up with a good execution
on a good financial plan well done sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
grant is with us in phoenix hi grant
welcome to ramsay show
hey dave thank you for having me on sure
what's up hey there
um so my question is i i own three homes
right now uh two of them which i own
outright
and the market out here in phoenix is
kind of crazy
and i wanted to know if you think it'd
be worth selling them and hanging on to
the cash for a little while and
reinvesting later or taking that money
and putting it towards what i owe on the
home i live in right now
if you sold both of them with the home
you're in be paid off
it would
and how much would you have left over
uh none
okay
all right so
um i owe about 490 on the home i'm in
right now
and i could sell both of my homes for
you know right around that what's your
household income
uh i make about 200 000 and my
girlfriend makes about 60. okay
all right
so your household income is 200 because
your girlfriend is your girlfriend okay
yeah okay yeah 200. the uh uh
how old are you
i'm 31. you're doing really good man
congratulations i'm sorry well i
appreciate it
um
this is going to feel extreme
but it's what i have done
and it has worked out
okay
preface it with that
i would sell them and i would pay off my
house
and then i would use up the fat use the
fact that you make 200 000 a year and
you have zero debt of any kind and
you're 31 years old to pile up a pile of
cash and by the time you do that this
market will have calmed down
and then buy an investment property with
cash
and then when that one is sitting there
with cash and you don't have a house
payment and you have rent coming in and
you make 200 a year you can pile up
money to buy the second rental property
with cash even quicker and then when
those two are paying rent and there's no
payments and you don't have any payments
on your house and you make 200 000 a
year you can pile up the cash to buy the
third one even quicker
and that's how i started buying real
estate the second time and i've not been
forced to sell any of it ever again and
i'm not at any financial stress ever
again
by doing that it's a little slower
but it's a little short a little more
sure and 20 years from now you'll be
ahead of the guy who leverages into him
right and honestly i probably over
purchased on the home i'm living in
um but i did that based on the rents i
was receiving from both homes that are
paid off in attempts to cover my
mortgage but
um that's my biggest payment i have to
worry about every month and the the
thing is you make a lot of money
and uh
you know you got somebody special in
your life so you may even be making more
money if you were to marry
and uh so you know you've got a nothing
but upside on this
and you'll be a you'll be a surprise
that how quickly you can save up and pay
cash now rule number one when you're
buying investment real estate is you do
not pay full price
okay so when you have a pilot
when you have two hundred thousand
dollars saved that it took you four
years to save or three years to save
after your homes paid off you you use
that to buy a 250 or 300 000 appraised
house not a 200 000 house you get a deal
when you have that kind of cash and you
wait until you can find a deal there are
no deals in this current marketplace
hardly
i mean very very hard to find a deal
right now because any old thing will
sell quickly and for too much money
right this second
um and so it's a good time to be getting
out of the market it's a horrible time
to get into the market and i'm not
necessarily i don't really care if the
market's hot or not i just don't want it
to be so hot that there's zero deals
because i'm always looking for a deal
we don't buy real estate at full price
at ramsey
that's not an investor that's what
investors should never do that so i want
to turn you into a cash investor that's
looking for a bargain
and you wait until you get a bargain and
you're a cash investor until you're just
looking for a bargain and you wait until
you get a bargain you're a cash investor
that's looking for you get the pattern
here there's a pattern to this and dude
it's going to set you free it's going to
put you in a whole different place now
very unpopular with the i borrow money
for everything crowd but i'm from the i
don't borrow money for anything crowds
and that's who you called
so
i think we could do the math dave and
let's say
like we're here in nashville and people
are over i don't say overpaying but the
list price is x and they're paying 25 or
50 higher than that
and let's say you buy that house and it
corrects down 50
saving money for six months
the math works out in your favor even
though no i don't know that the market
is going to correct down okay
i think all that's going to be is just
there's going to be a little less
shooting up okay and it's and the frenzy
is going to come off okay when the
frenzy comes off when supply catches up
with demand right then when somebody's
you know when people aren't running up
to the front door and nailing offers to
the front door you know uh like it's
just it's crazy when that stops then
there's actually a foreclosure that can
be bought out of the deal
there's a bank uh owned real estate that
can be bought at a deal there's other
stuff you can find you know estate plant
house you know two sisters own a house
they live in chicago the house is in
nashville it's been sitting there on the
market for a while they don't want it
they never wanted it in the first place
they just got stuck with it or airbnb
or yeah whatever it is you get a deal
whatever the cause of someone becoming a
motivated seller but in a market where
there's seven buyers for every house
that goes on the market 20 minutes after
it goes on the market that
no one has to take a deal but and what
i'm saying is after a let's say a year
the frenzy level's off you're holding
cash here you didn't lose no not having
a rental property you actually did okay
yeah by just because again you're going
to use the 200 000 cash to buy a 300 000
house that's right
or a 260 000 house or whatever it is and
so you make your money back on the deal
right the fact that you're buying at a
bargain in a marketplace where market
bargains might exist in a marketplace
like we're in today they don't exist
that's right just because of the simple
the frenzy the frenzy took all the
foreclosures out of the market but you
can feel like you're losing right now
and you're not yeah that's a good that's
a good clarification and you're not
you're not
richard's in
pensacola florida hi richard how are you
hey dave
what's up
uh
first i want to thank you so much for
all your great advice over the years
uh you've been like a little angel on my
shoulder the voice of reason
bless you
man what's your devil what's the devil
on the other shoulder like well the
devil's my wife on the other side
whoa
uh anyway quickly i'm 66 years old my
wife is 56 years old i have two
beautiful successful daughters we're
debt-free
i've got about 75k in a roth and i've
got about 50 000 in cash
and my two daughters the the house that
we live in is worth about four hundred
thousand
and they don't need the inheritance and
they're not interested in they don't
want the house
and i probably know your answer but is a
reverse reverse mortgage ever a good
idea no
damn yeah the uh the interest rates are
higher and the default rate is higher
because these things are a dead gum mess
i mean when washed up movie stars are
pitching them on tv right next to
walk-in bathtubs and snuggies you know
it's not a good deal
okay
well i want to buy a motorhome and me
and my wife want to travel around the
country well if you want to move down
the house i'm okay with that
yeah gosh she doesn't want to move she
loves this old house yeah we just did it
we just moved into half the house we're
doing it this week's matter of fact we
sold our house we're moving into half
the house now we used some of the money
to buy another vacation house and you
could use some of the money and buy a
home be the same thing
so if you moved into a 300 000 house and
bought a 50 000 motor home you know that
would have been an okay move
but i would do that but i don't know
well she doesn't have to i mean you can
rent a motor home too you'll have to buy
one yeah they go down in value
they're horrible
we rent boats we don't buy boats we rent
them when we want to use one that's not
it's not a bad thing because they go
down in value like crazy
so yeah reverse mortgage is a really bad
bad product and i would stay completely
away from it under any circumstances
it just has a mess the average default
rate with typical mortgages is three
percent the average default rate among
reverse mortgages is 18 percent that
gives you a hint right there how bad
these things are
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first peter 4 10
each of you should use whatever gift you
have received to serve others as a
faithful steward of god's grace in its
various forms
edmund burke said nobody made a greater
mistake than he who did nothing because
he could
do only a little
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five darcy's with us
in houston texas hey darcy how are you
all right how you guys doing today
great how's it going
oh joy
so what's up how can we help
uh well basically i just need some
guidance some
real guidance and i've
done a financial peace university a very
very long time ago so
and i
was it i tried it failed it tried it
again failed it kept going back and
forth and now back around to it again
i'm now at a position where i have i'm a
disabled vet and i work full time so i'm
receiving money i'm receiving like two
incomes i'm a single parent i'm trying
to basically just
figure out what to do i have a kid
that's going to college in a couple
years and i have nothing
i have
i have nothing for him but fortunately
because i was a vet i still have um
he'll be able to go to school in state
for free
um
why did you fail fpu
you said you took it several times why
did you fail
because i couldn't uh i wasn't working
when i couldn't um
due to part of the things going on with
my disability or whatever i was unable
to work
what is the nature of your disability
honey
uh it
it was physical
physical and mental okay
so at one point i wasn't able to work
but now i am working a full-time job and
i'm able to uh and i'm able to do
uh
i'm able to do this day by day
and i also hopefully here hopefully i'm
also looking for another job
within the system to pay more money so
what do you make of a disability
disability
it will be at 40
at 40 000.
and what do you make on your other job
i'm a job uh
after taxes and everything it'll be 31.
i just did that how many kids have you
got
two
and how old are they
16 14. okay
all right you did not fail fpu because
you lost your job
that's not true
you failed fpu because you lost your
focus and that might be true because of
some of the mental things you're facing
i don't know
um yeah or it could be or it could be it
was more like me i was just lazy
i don't know you got to decide that i'm
not going to put it on you you got to
decide but
thank you for your service by the way
but you can do financial peace
university making 40 000 a year and you
didn't stop getting that disability
when you lost no i wasn't what no no no
no i i wasn't making anywhere near that
at that time that's it
you got nowhere near you you got your
disability income didn't you
yeah yeah but
yeah no no it wasn't but it wasn't but
it wasn't that high it wasn't all the
disability income has been adjusted
yes it has it has increased
in this last
uh
hold on i lied about that number a lot
but wait a minute
what's the real number i i think i'm 44.
so are you are you here's the question
that every person's got ultimately
decide
you've got a 14 year old a 16 year old
and they're important they're your why
but also
you have to look in the mirror and
decide i'm ready to change my life
oh yeah i'm ready i'm ready like like
then your past doesn't matter
yeah
all you can control is tomorrow morning
that's it
yeah
and you've had some hard challenges and
some ugly challenges you've seen war
you've seen all kinds of mess
and here you are and what you get to
decide is what tomorrow's going to look
like
are you ready to change your life
oh yeah most definitely are you certain
of it
oh most definitely
it's going to have to change the way you
talk to yourself the way you think about
yourself the way you champion yourself
in those kids
the way you look at them and say hey we
got free college in the state we're
gonna we're gonna run with it and you
can breathe the way you start saving
money follow the baby steps it's going
to be a totally different way of talking
to darcy
are you ready
of course i am you can't say people like
me
don't win you can't say that anymore
because people like you now win because
that's you are a different people
yeah
yeah that's what that decision does are
you ready i don't trust you yet i don't
either
i am ready i am ready are you going to
count the cost of what it's going to
cost you we may have to get new fringe
you may have to tell your kids hey y'all
got to get jobs
you make 71 000 a year now and you're
broke
not now not now not now i have i have
almost 30 000 in the bank right now and
how much debt do you have
huh and how much debt do you have
and
that i don't know the answer to i just
got how much debt
i don't i don't know really
i
what are you on that car you bought
oh you know what i don't i paid off my
car already i don't have any debt on
that student loans uh
no student loans credit cards
i don't have any credit cards medical
medical debt that's a different story i
have a son that's special needs
and uh
that that is from that other than
and
i'm still fighting with the insurance on
that one but other than that what kind
of debt have you got
my house note okay other than those two
things what have you got
and um
i had a loan stupid me i had a loan and
i'm like at 18 on that and i'm thinking
about just level because i've been
doubling up on my house because i i was
like well let me go ahead
before that loan happen let me double up
on my house or whatever and that's what
i've been doing so darcy listen listen
you're creating chaos
and what you need what you need is peace
you're trying to double up over here not
pay over there call insurance company
over here then triple up over here and
go back and not pay that and it just
creates this chaos this frenzy
and what dave's trying to give you is
peace
you know so here's what we're going to
do you hold on kelly's going to pick up
i'm going to sign you up for a fresh
class of financial peace university i'm
going to pay for it as a part of a
ramsey plus membership
and that's how you access financial
peace university now
it also includes the every dollar
premium app
and darcy
this time i want you to follow orders
like you're in the military and bring
your boys along with you this time i
want you to do everything
exactly
like we tell you to do it no
variance
i want you to stick with it exactly
because you never heard me one time back
when you went through a pu tell you to
pay double on your house while you're
sitting on a stupid 18 alone
that's so discombobulated kiddo
and you can do better than this um
even with all the different things you
got in your life even with the different
challenges
but you need a very very clear path
and a very clear line and you don't get
off the line
you stay right on the line one foot in
front of the other
follow the recipe exactly
and we'll make some great gumbo
but if you don't if you go make up your
own stuff don't expect it to turn out
because that's what happened between the
time you left financial peace university
the first time
and now
is you never once applied the exact
recipe
and it would never have you paying extra
on your house would never have you
dealing with that you don't know what's
going on with these medical bills you
don't have a clear organized
precise plan
and that precision is where your peace
will come from it requires some extra
work
and you kind of sweat and have a little
stress while you're doing it
but the end result is you are now on top
of the numbers managing them they're not
managing you and you get to choose your
hard from this point forward you want to
live in chaos and
payment to payment to payment to
or do you want to work really hard for a
couple of years and breathe and sleep
choose your heart that's the way it
works you can do it kiddo hold on kelly
will pick up
good show john
dr john doloney james childs kelly in
the booth i'm dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you